Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank"...
Powell: Bunch Bikes
is sharing the joy
of family biking
across the country.
What would happen if you
pulled back the curtain?
[ Screams ]
Who wants to milk this deal
for all it's worth?
You have sales
out the wazoo, right?
$600 worth.
‐Wow.
‐Oh.
That right there is a necessity
for the family.
The problem for me is
it's not your product.
Corcoran: I'll give you
a very greedy offer.
I want 40%.
John: Oh!
This product
howls at the moon.
That breaks their spirit.
I'm gonna give you
$2 million.
‐Whoa!
‐Oh!
‐Wow!
Lori, do you have...?
Are you crazy?
What are you doing?
I love this stuff.
Welcome to "Shark Tank."
♪♪
Narrator:
First into the Tank
is a better way
to enjoy plant‐based milk.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Ari Tolwin.
And I'm Joe Savino.
We're from New York,
and we're seeking
$1 million...
Oh.
...in exchange for 5%
of our business.
Oh.
Corcoran: Wow.
Whoa.
You got our attention.
Sharks, milk today means
something totally different
from what the milk man used
to deliver to our homes.
Sure, some of us
still drink cow's milk,
but most of us have switched
to almond milk, oat milk,
or even hemp milk.
But, Sharks,
that comes at a price.
Most of those milks
are hyper‐processed,
filled with gums,
preservatives,
and fillers galore.
Well, Sharks,
that's where we come in.
Both: Moo‐ve on over,
cow's milk.
Because making fresh,
dairy‐free milk
just became
"udderly" easy.
Introducing...
Numilk.
We built a custom machine
for grocery stores
where shoppers can make
delicious, nutritious,
pure, dairy‐free milk
at the push of a button.
We use
the best ingredients.
Organic almonds from Spain
for our almond milks.
A blend of organic cacao,
vanilla bean, and maple
for our chocolate milks.
And a whole lot more.
Our Numilks are homemade
without the mess or the fuss.
We're on a mission
to bring plant‐based diets
and zero‐waste lifestyles
to the world.
So, Sharks,
I just have one question.
Who wants to milk this deal
for all it's worth?
[ Laughter ]
Sharks, in front of you
are a flight
of delicious dairy‐free milks
for each of you to try.
But before you do so,
Mark, you've mentioned
you're dairy‐free.
Come on up and make some
fresh milk for yourself.
Sure.
♪♪
So, you can select
almond milk or oat milk.
I'm gonna go with almond milk
'cause I've had it,
so I'll know what it
tastes like in comparison.
Great.
So, just press
that almond milk button
and then "Start"
on the bottom.
So, the machine is actually
making it fresh.
It's not a concentrate
or anything else in there.
It's taking pure, organic
almonds from Valencia
and making the milk
right now.
That's fast.
That's cool.
♪♪
The almond milk's
very good.
It tastes nothing
like the store brand.
Cuban: The milk I just made
is incredible.
You can tell
it's fresh almonds.
It's incredible.
Just to understand
what's in the machine,
give us the choices.
So, the first thing
about Numilk
is that we're really
a food‐tech company,
and we built a platform.
Right now, we have almond milk
and oat milk in there,
but we could do cashew.
We could do hemp.
If that becomes popular,
we could do sesame.
It's really limitless.
So,
how long does it last,
and what would be
the expiration date
on one of these?
Great question.
It'll have a 7‐
to 10‐day shelf life,
and it has to stay
in the fridge.
O'Leary: I mean,
I think that's
the 1,000‐pound gorilla
in the room.
Coming to the "Shark Tank,"
you want to think big, right?
Both: Right.
You're asking
for a million bucks.
Obviously,
you need capital
to build out and lease
these machines
to all the locations.
That's a different
kind of business model
because they require
maintenance.
They require the capital
to build them.
Yeah.
And then you also
have to get the space
inside the grocery store
to give you what looks to me
like about 10 square feet.
Tolwin: Barbara, you're
a real‐estate mogul.
You understand the value
of square footage.
I'll tell you
exactly what it is
in midtown Manhattan
for a street location.
It's $3,000 a foot
in a primary location.
Yep.
How big is that?
So,
it's eight square feet.
The machines average $50,000
per year, per machine.
And so, when you think
about it on a square f‐‐
That's in revenue.
In revenue, yep.
And it's unmanned,
and we pay no rent
at all.
What does a machine cost?
The machines
are $30,000 each.
They'll come down
to $15,000 at scale.
John: You know, guys,
I think it's a genius idea.
Number one, you're
reducing grocery stores'
perishable loss,
right?
Yes.
Number two is, you're
attracting new customers.
I like that
whole concept.
But were you
in this area before
in traditional
business?
Yeah.
Like, tell us a little bit
about yourselves.
Yeah, so I come from
the food‐and‐beverage world.
Before this,
I did aviation catering
for commercial jets,
private jets.
So, if you guys
flew to New York,
you have eaten our food.
Then I started
my own co‐packing company
doing food and beverages.
After that, I left,
and I started this with Ari.
I'm also a second‐time
entrepreneur in the space.
I had a brand called
Happytree Maple Water.
I had national distribution
in about 8,000 stores.
Did you have a exit
on that water company?
No. I shut it down, actually,
after we started this.
Corcoran:
I have a question.
What would Mark pay for that
bottle of almond milk
that he took away?
Yeah, you'd pay $2
for the bottle.
That's a one‐time charge.
And if you
brought it back,
you'd pay $3.99
to refill it.
Okay, it's $3.99
for the almond milk,
$2 for the bottle.
How much goes
to the grocery store?
Yep. So, the grocery store
takes about a third.
O'Leary: All right, so,
how much have you raised?
We've raised $12 million.
‐Whoa!
‐Oh!
‐Wow!
What was the last
valuation?
Our last valuation
was $40 million pre‐money.
So we've actually negotiated
with our investors in advance
to give you
a Shark‐appropriate deal.
Guys, is there
a bigger picture here?
This is obviously
a big picture.
Yes.
Hit 'em, Joe.
So, this is our
countertop device.
Oh!
And this is the bottle
that goes with it.
Ooh!
Wow.
We took our
grocery machine,
we shrunk it down so it works
on your countertops.
So you can
have the best ‐‐
Now, that right there
is a necessity
for the family, I think.
What is that going
to cost the consumer?
It's gonna be about
$85 landed.
That's your cost.
What was your plan to sell it
to them for, then?
$199.
Can you show us how
the small machine works?
This is actually just
a 3D rendering prototype.
O'Leary: Okay, guys,
let's get into the numbers.
Just the basics, please.
Yep.
Top line, bottom line.
Last three years.
Yeah.
So, 2018,
$40,000 of revenue.
One machine,
partial year.
What'd you lose?
Spent a lot on R&D.
So we spent about
$2 million on R&D in 2018.
Losses were 2 mil.
Correct,
approximately.
2019.
$320 topline.
We ended the year
with 10 machines.
How much did you lose
in 2019?
And then we spent
$3 million on R&D.
So, $5 million
total losses so far.
Now we're getting
to some critical mass here.
Wow.
Yeah.
What happens
in the third year?
So, third year
is this year.
We would have ended the year
at about a $6 million year.
But because of coronavirus,
our launch with Kroger,
some growth with Whole Foods,
a launch with Gelson's,
and some other regional
retailers were delayed.
So, what do you think
the losses will be this year?
This year, it's gonna
be about $2 million,
as well, mostly R&D ‐‐
So, 7 mil
in the ground so far.
And how much cash
do you have in the bank?
$3.5 million.
John:
You projected $6 million,
but where do you think
you'll land now?
This year, we're gonna be like
400k by the end of the year.
In sales?
Yeah.
Wait, wait. I'm sorry.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
You said you projected
$6 million for this year,
but you feel you're gonna
end at $400,000.
Yeah, so, we would have
ended it with 100 machines
at the end of the year.
Can I get your attention
just for a moment, please?
I've been sitting here
and listening to every word.
I still don't get it, and I'm
paying attention like crazy.
Actually, I'm sitting here
feeling like I'm back
in second grade
failing again...
Cuban: [ Laughs ]
...because I don't know
what the hell
the teacher's talking
about yet again.
You talk so much
that I can't grab
a single word.
I'm sure you've got
something good there.
I don't know what the heck
it is, but I'm out.
I'm confused, too.
I'm out.
♪♪
Lori, you can help us
bring this
to millions of people
around the world.
And I see you maybe
struggling a little bit,
but I think
you want to do it.
Greiner:
Problem for me is,
you know, you only have
so much time in here.
There's a lot to explain
about your business model.
Right.
And I don't think
we've gotten
a lot of those
answers out.
You're asking for
a million dollars for 5%.
You're losing money.
This is a prototype,
so you don't even know yet.
We don't know
if it works.
We actually have five
of these countertops
in the field,
but they're stainless steel
models for coffee shops.
You came in asking
for a pretty hefty sum.
It's just not investable
for me right now.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Joe, what do you sell
the stainless‐steel
commercial unit for?
$699.
And what do they
cost you to make?
300 bucks.
O'Leary:
All right, guys, look,
I thought you were nuts
when you first walked out here,
but now I have
a different opinion.
You did a very good job
in presenting the opportunity.
Thank you.
I don't agree
with my fellow Sharks.
I get what you're doing.
It's extremely interesting.
♪♪
I'm gonna make you
an offer.
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out,
but Kevin is interested
in Joe and Ari's
plant‐based milk machine,
Numilk.
O'Leary:
I thought you were nuts
when you first
walked out here,
but now I have
a different opinion.
I'm gonna make you
an offer.
I actually think there's
a huge fundamental demand
for your product,
and I love watching Mark
go nuts over plant‐based stuff.
You know,
I'm a modified vegan.
I only eat vegan
on Tuesdays.
[ Laughter ]
So...
He's serious.
...the structure
is difficult here,
because you've already raised
so much capital.
I would stick this
in my venture debt fund,
and I do an offer
like this.
I will loan you
a million dollars
at 9 1/2% interest
for 3 years.
That will cost you
$8,000 a month,
and I will take 5% equity
that you offered.
You know, I don't know
what Mark's gonna do,
but it gets you
into my sphere
of the Shark world,
and you can talk
to any of my entrepreneurs.
I do a hell of a job
on digital for them.
So if you're going
after consumers,
I can help you.
Yeah, so, first of all,
we really appreciate the offer.
We do believe you can bring
a lot of value to the business.
It's not what we had in mind
when we walked in here.
So we want to
at least get to engage ‐‐
But it's an offer.
Absolutely.
It's great.
And believe me,
I was not planning
on giving you a million bucks
when I first saw this thing.
♪♪
Cuban: Okay, so,
here's the thing.
So, you've got $3 million
left in the bank
for two products.
I obviously love
the stainless‐steel version
that you're putting in
coffee shops right now.
I think that'll sell
like hotcakes at home.
I think you'll sell
a million units easily.
You have it priced
at $699.
I think it could be priced
at $899.
And given your margin,
at that price,
you make $500 a unit.
That's a lot of money.
But with just $3 million
in the bank,
between marketing,
right,
and inventory and receivables
and everything else,
you're not gonna have
enough cash.
So you guys know coming in
you're gonna have to negotiate,
so let's just
cut to the chase.
5% is not enough.
Can you do 6%?
♪♪
No.
What do you want?
♪♪
Okay, guys, here's my offer.
I'm gonna give you $2 million.
You only asked for $1 million.
$1 million of that is going
to be for 7% equity.
The other million
is going to be a loan
at 3% interest,
but I get an additional
3% of stock
as advisory shares
or straight‐up equity.
But if you don't
use the loan,
you don't have to give me
the 3% equity for that loan.
So, in total,
if you use all the capital,
it's $2 million for 10%.
♪♪
Do you have a little bit
of flexibility?
We really want
to work with you.
You can help us
grow this.
It can be awesome.
A major global success.
Do you have a little bit
of flexibility?
That was my flexibility.
It's a great offer, Mark.
We love it.
Depends how much you want
to change the world.
Is 1% gonna change ‐‐
No flexibility?
We're at 5%. 7%.
Can't do 6%?
You came in
asking for a million,
and now you have access
to $2 million.
♪♪
You got a deal.
Deal. Yes, sir.
All right.
Appreciate it, guys.
O'Leary:
Oh, that was ‐‐
John: Phew.
Joe, you spoke up
at the right moment.
Congratulations,
guys.
[ Laughs ]
Good luck
with everything.
We accept
the congratulations,
but the work
starts now.
Exactly right.
♪♪
We just did a $2 million
deal with Mark Cuban.
Whoo!
[ Laughs ]
He beat us up a little bit
at the end,
but we couldn't be more
excited to work with him
and continue to grow Numilk
to be a great success.
♪♪
Narrator:
Earlier this season,
Riki and Oron Franco
made a deal with Kevin O'Leary
for their sustainable
charcoal briquettes, Prime 6.
Kevin, you have a deal.
Let's see what
they're up to now.
Oron: We created our
compressed sawdust charcoal
with the goal
of burning longer,
but also to have a positive
effect on the planet
and save trees.
For each pack purchased,
we plant one tree.
When we pitched
to the Sharks,
we'd done $300,000
in sales.
It's only been three months
since "Shark Tank,"
and we have already done
$1.3 million in sales
and purchase orders.
Since "Shark Tank,"
we've already planted
more than 20,000 trees,
and we've repurposed
1 million tons of sawdust.
Because of the effects
of COVID‐19,
our restaurant service sales
have decreased by 85%.
But with so many people
stuck at home ‐‐
grilling more,
cooking more ‐‐
it allowed us to expand
and reach all 50 states.
We are rolling out
in 5,000 new stores
like Krogers and Safeway
and Giant Foods.
We are so blessed
that people want to put
sustainable products
on their shelf
and show consumers
an alternative
to what's out there.
You are becoming
carbon neutral.
You're the classic
sustainability model.
The reason companies
with a mission
are so important is,
people care.
They want to know
what you stand for.
It's not just about
making a buck.
It's about making
the world better.
This is gonna be
a great success story.
I knew it when I saw it
on "Shark Tank."
Think about Riki
and Oron.
They are
the American dream.
They came to America
to have a better life.
They come up
with a better product.
I love this story.
I love delivering this freedom
to this young family.
When we started this,
we were selling it
from the back of our car,
and to think that
we would be
in tens of thousands
of households ‐‐
to tell our kids that Prime 6
is a company now
and not just a passion ‐‐
it's just
an incredible impact
that we're having
in people's lives
and on the environment
and for our own kids.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a solution
to a hairy problem.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Andy Watne,
and this is
my wife, Patty.
Hi.
We're from
Orland Park, Illinois.
Imagine, if you will,
a situation.
A situation
involving a shower ‐‐
be it yours, a friend's,
or a mysteriously placed shower
like right here.
What would happen
if you pulled back the curtain
after your family member
or roommate
had taken a shower and...
♪♪
[ Screams ]
[ Laughter ]
You have now entered
the Hairy Zone.
Stop! I can't take it!
[ Laughing ]
Well, then,
maybe you should stop
wiping your hair
on the shower wall.
Oh.
[ Laughs ]
Sharks, I promise, I have
the best of intentions.
When we wash our hair,
some of it comes out, right?
It's natural.
And for a lot of people,
that wet hair
ends up tangled
all over your hands
like this.
Greiner: Ew.
[ Laughing ]
John: Ugh,
that's disgusting.
And after struggling
to remove the wet hair,
you end up wiping it
all over the shower wall.
That's why we invented
the HairyGrabster.
♪♪
It's just this easy.
[ Laughter ]
The hairy bristles
grab and trap
the loose hair
off your hands.
[ Laughing ]
Oh, my God.
It's not going
down the drain,
and it's not being wiped
all over the walls
for the next person
to find.
HairyGrabster
is the first
and only product
on the market
to offer a quick
and easy way
to remove hair
from the hands
and keep it in place
while washing.
[ Laughter ]
So, Sharks, who's tired
of this hairy situation
and ready to...
grab one today?
Grab one today!
We're here
seeking $75,000
in exchange for 20%
of our company.
Please check out
your samples.
Cuban:
First, let me say,
this is probably
the best product name
of anything that's ever
come on "Shark Tank."
Well, thank you!
HairyGrabster
will be memorable forever.
Well, what's your history?
Are you product designers?
Are you...?
I was a floor trader
for about 10 years.
After that,
I transitioned, then,
into project management.
I grew up in my family's
flower shop.
Our family business
is over 100 years old
in Chicago and suburbs.
And so, after
graduating from IU...
What?!
I know!
Hoo‐Hoo‐Hoo‐Hoosiers!
[ Laughter ]
So, after I graduated
from Indiana,
I worked at the shop.
I mostly did sales
until we started adding
more and more children
to our family.
How many kids
do you have?
We have three.
After HairyGrabster's
grabbed the hair,
how do you get the hair
out of the Grabster?
It's just like cleaning
out a hairbrush.
You might not have
a lot of...
In Kevin's case,
he would save the hair.
Kevin might not
have a lot of experience
with cleaning out
a hairbrush.
I was thinking I could
just stick this
on the top of my head
after it's full of hair.
Well, there you go.
[ Laughter ]
We've got
an after‐product.
Let's go
into the economics.
What do you sell these for,
and what's it cost you
to make?
Landed, they're $1.30,
and we are selling
at $9.95.
How much have you sold
year‐to‐date?
Probably ‐‐
About $600 worth.
And what are you doing to, like,
tell the world about it?
600 units or $600?
Dollars.
$600.
‐Oh. Okay, you just started.
‐Right.
So, 60 units.
Are you putting out, like,
any type of social media ads?
We're doing
Facebook ads,
posting on
our Facebook pages.
O'Leary:
Are you making money
on the Facebook buys?
In other words, when you
look at what you spend
versus what you bring in
on the margin.
Uh, at this time, no.
That's not good.
But we're looking
at it as ‐‐
It's brand‐new to me.
Do you remember a product
called DrainWig?
Oh, we absolutely know
about the DrainWig. Yeah.
That's my deal.
Yep.
And that thing has been
a big surprise.
It's amazing that
the guy with no hair
does all the hair stuff,
but that thing goes
down a drain...
Aspirational.
...and collects hair,
and then it's pulled out.
Many people
who buy the DrainWig
don't bother to clean it.
They throw it out
and spend another nine bucks
just sticking
a new one down.
So we get repeat, repeat,
over and over again.
Why isn't the HairyGrabster
in the same boat?
At this point,
it's price point.
And you wouldn't want to
throw this out.
I mean, honestly,
this is plastic.
No, that's really
wasteful...
You just want to sell it any way
people will buy it, right?
...to throw this out.
Doesn't matter, yeah.
It's not sustainable.
It's wasteful.
The DrainWig
also doesn't address
the issue of the hair
on your hands.
The hair ‐‐
How'd you come up
with this idea?
The whole way we came up
with this idea was,
all of a sudden,
Andy calls me
into the bathroom one day,
very concerned.
And he was like, "I think
there's something wrong
with our daughter.
Look at all this hair
on the shower wall."
And he had no idea
that when people have
longer hair and wash it,
that it comes out.
What are you gonna
use the money for?
Getting our name
out there,
getting people aware
that you have this problem.
We have the solution.
You have a solution
that people don't know
they need,
and that's the problem.
I think you have a lot more
things to figure out ‐‐
packaging,
various other things.
Best of luck to you,
but this isn't for me.
I'm out.
Okay, thank you
very much.
Patty and Andy, where I see
the problem here is,
I don't think it's a big
enough problem to solve.
And the second thing is,
I would rather
have the hair on my wall
than see this thing
hanging out
with all the hair.
I think that's equally ugly.
And so, I'm not sold
on the product, quite honestly,
so I'm out.
I actually don't want
the HairyGrabster
to ever make it
to the market.
This is definitely competitive
to what I'm doing and selling
and have been for years.
I also don't think
it's a big enough problem.
This is never
going to work.
I'm out.
Okay, thank you.
I like things
that solve a big problem.
I think this is
a niche market,
and it could be a good
little business for you,
but I don't see this
as being something
investable for me.
And so, I'm sorry.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Guys, how many units
do you have in inventory?
About ‐‐
We have about 5,000.
Yep.
Okay, how much
have you invested so far?
$63,000
of our own money.
Wow.
Cuban: I mean, my only
suggestion to you guys is,
take 500 of those units
and get them to people
with long hair.
Find an influencer
that you might know.
And I would give them to all
of your daughter's friends
and just say,
"You know what, guys?
Give us feedback."
Maybe that'll
create some ideas,
because you have to find out
what sells your product,
because you don't know yet.
I wish you the best of luck,
but it's not a fit for me,
so I'm out.
♪♪
I think you should really
do a little soul‐searching.
It's important
not to take a dog
and run with it too long.
You're nice people,
but this product
howls at the moon.
Greiner:
Good luck, you guys.
Cuban: Good luck, guys.
‐Good luck.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Thank you all very much.
Patty: This is
absolutely not the end
for HairyGrabster.
We're going to go ahead
with our plans
to launch further online,
and we're gonna
keep moving forward.
The product sucks.
Are you kidding?
I would have to agree
that the product sucks ‐‐
no doubt ‐‐
but what's wrong with ‐‐
You really think
the product sucks?
Yes, but what is wrong
with what you do
is you say,
"It howls at the moon."
That breaks their spirit.
Why would you
have to end ‐‐
No, it doesn't!
It gives them
the information they need!
Yes.
They have to be ready.
Oh, come on.
You know, maybe it goes to
the bottom of an aquarium.
John: [ Laughs ]
♪♪
Narrator:
Next into the Tank
is a brand that caters
to an underserved market.
♪♪
Hey there, Sharks.
My name is Oliver Zak,
and I'm from
Cleveland, Ohio.
And I'm Selom Agbitor
from Accra, Ghana.
Today, we are seeking
$500,000
in exchange for 5%
of our tattoo
aftercare company.
[ Sharks groan ]
What the French toast?!
A work of art
is meant to be treasured
for years and years.
Even Picasso and DaVinci
have had their
paintings restored
to their vibrant beginnings
from years ago.
So, why not give
that same love and care
to the art on your body?
That's right ‐‐ we're talking
about your tattoos.
Cuban: [ Chuckles ]
Being permanent exhibitions
on our bodies,
tattoos require constant
maintenance and upkeep
to continue
looking healthy.
With that in mind,
Mad Rabbit was formulated
with seven
all‐natural ingredients
that keep tattoos
looking vibrant
and prevent
ink discoloration.
As you can see,
the skin immediately
responds to application,
restoring their ink back to the
vibrant works of art
they were meant to be.
Customers of all
skin tones and types
already swear by Mad Rabbit
as being their go‐to product
to keep their old tattoos
looking as good as new.
People have invested
thousands of dollars
and time
into their tattoos.
Mad Rabbit is here to
help them last a lifetime.
So, Sharks, who's ready
to ink a deal?
Greiner: Hah.
So, I have a question.
You said that when you put this
on your tattoo,
it actually makes
the colors more vibrant.
What helps
make it brighter?
The fact that you're
giving it deep moisture...
Exactly.
...so therefore, it doesn't
look dry and dull?
Absolutely.
What about a tattoo
that's already
started to fade?
It helps bring it
back to life.
O'Leary: Why would it
bring it back?
Because the ink
is subdermal, is it not?
Right, so it's not actually
affecting the ink itself.
It's moisturizing the layer
of skin on top of it
which helps it ‐‐
It's just to make it
appear that way,
so you have to keep on
reapplying to keep it ‐‐
Exactly, but the more
you moisturize your tattoo,
the less it fades
over time.
John: Let's go through
your backstory,
and then let's get to the part
where you stole my high school
graduation picture
off the Internet.
[ Laughter ]
And then we can move forward.
All right, so,
I'll begin.
Today's actually
my 24th birthday.
Happy birthday!
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
So, I was born
in Ghana, West Africa.
Like every
immigrant family,
my parents wanted me
to become a doctor,
lawyer, engineer,
or something in finance,
but I always wanted
to be an artist.
But then, I knew that
once I got to college,
I'd have student loans
and have to pay back
my college debt,
so I enrolled in university
as a finance major.
And then, after graduation,
I currently work
in corporate finance
in Dallas, Texas.
Zak: My passion
for entrepreneurship
really started from watching
my father rise from the ashes.
In 2003, he was a surgeon,
got in a car accident,
injured his spine,
and he couldn't operate
because his hand shakes.
You know,
he reinvented himself,
and he is now
an entrepreneur.
So, I knew entrepreneurship
was the thing for me, right?
That's what I wanted
to do long‐term.
But where did
the tattoo part come in?
So, that's always been
a passion of ours.
We've always thought
tattoos were so cool.
I obviously don't have
any visible ones.
But, yeah.
[ Laughs ]
Let's talk about
Mad Rabbit.
Let's talk Mad Rabbit.
You basically want $500,000 ‐‐
I'm intrigued ‐‐
for 5%, imputing a $10 million
valuation.
$10 million.
Because you have sales
out the wazoo, right?
Of course, yeah.
We do.
$300,000.
That's it?!
Greiner: What?!
No way.
Last month.
Sharks: Oh!
In the past eight months,
we've done $1.7 million.
Good for you guys.
Good for you.
John: Wow!
Agbitor: We started this
in January ‐‐
In this alone?
Yeah, just one product.
Zak: One product.
That's our
one‐product story.
And you started
January when?
January 2019
was when we started,
and that first year,
we did over $400,000.
So we've grown a lot
in the past 18 months.
Who did you sell it to,
and how?
That's remarkable.
Thank you.
Well, we're
direct‐to‐consumer right now,
so we only sell
on our website.
Good.
But how did you
promote sales there?
That's a tremendous amount
of sales in a short period.
Zak: We've spent a lot
of our marketing money
on content and, actually,
tattoo education.
We put a ton
of time and effort
into researching what
works best for tattoos,
what ingredients
work best,
and getting feedback
from our customers
and then iterating
on our product.
You guys have become
the cool tattoo brand,
basically, right?
We are the cool
tattoo brand.
Yeah. We are.
Yeah, people are using it.
And so, do you have
subscription service?
Exactly. Yes, we do.
Yes, we do.
And how many
subscribers do you have?
Over 5,000 subscribers.
There you go.
And what do you charge
per month?
$11.99.
And what does this
cost you?
$2.78.
Is there someone else out there
with these type of ingredients
that is a competitor
of yours, would you say?
Yeah, so, worldwide,
there's about 12 or so
tattoo "aftercare"
competitors.
We are the only
all‐natural one
selling in the U. S.
currently.
Are you having
a lot of artists
and people that everybody knows?
Or, you know,
is that the reason?
I'm trying to find the reason,
because there's something
special about what you're doing,
'cause your numbers
clearly say it.
So, for example,
a future NBA Hall‐of‐Famer
from the Miami Heat
actually reached out to us
asking about the product,
and he's been using it
for the past month now.
So it's organic, right?
It's been organic.
Zak: It's organic.
And you're not paying people
to do these things?
We are paying
some influencers.
Okay, so, tell us about
what you're doing there.
It depends on
the influencer, right?
So, we could have a top‐10
tattoo artist in the world
that we say, "Okay,
we need to pay $5,000
so he posts us."
We also have influencers
like these two models
who each have
their own following.
But the cool thing
about tattoos is,
everyone has tattoos
for different reasons.
So each of these influencers
kind of has
their own submarkets,
if that makes sense.
Right, right.
I want to find out your
customer acquisition cost.
It's sitting
between $6 or $7.
‐That's not bad.
‐That's really good.
Cuban: And so, tell us about
what you're doing
for content creation,
because what we're all
trying to figure out is,
what's the secret sauce?
I think our secret sauce is this
community of tight‐knit people
that we've been able to build.
We have thousands
of customer‐submitted photos.
Through our Instagram,
we post stories...
There you go.
...of people who ‐‐
We call them
"tattoo tours."
How many followers
on Insta?
90,000.
That's it?
And they're all organic.
No, that's not bad.
You guys are the real
"Tattoos of Instagram."
Right.
Okay, content creation.
How much do you spend
on that monthly?
So, last month,
we spent around
$85,000 in marketing.
So, you did $300,000
last month.
Yes.
How much did you make?
So, last month,
our net's sitting around
20% net profit margins
and around 60 ‐‐
So, you made about
60 grand last month.
And I get that you're
reinvesting it,
but I just wanted to see.
John: But one question ‐‐
And we may have gotten
to this already.
Selom, are you working
on this full‐time?
So, sadly, neither of us
are full‐time yet.
‐Got it. All right.
‐That's not sad.
I mean ‐‐
‐No, no.
There's no need for you
to be full‐time.
Yeah, look what
you're generating
and you're just
moonlighting it.
John: But this is
becoming to my question.
What do you think you're
gonna gross this year?
Off of one product,
we're expecting
to sell $3 million
this year.
How much did you invest in
the business in the beginning?
We started with $300 each,
and we were lucky enough
to be profitable from week one.
[ Laughs ]
Wow. That's
really amazing.
So, guys, let me tell you
what I think about this.
I'm not sure I agree
with your 10 valuation,
but I'm not gonna
fight you about it
because I'm gonna
restructure this in my way.
You don't have to do it.
[ Laughing ]
But the way I look at it ‐‐
‐I think I know what's coming.
No, but I'll tell you
what I would do.
I'll give you the $500,000
as a venture debt deal, okay?
I'm gonna charge you 9.75% ‐‐
the average of what I'm doing
venture debt at ‐‐
and I'll take 5% equity,
and I will get behind it
as a educator of tattoos.
[ Laughs ]
Thank you
for the offer, Kevin.
Thank you, Kevin.
I have a lot of respect
for you dudes.
You're not even full‐time yet,
and you're killing it.
Thank you.
Corcoran: Hey, guys,
you've really won my respect.
You seem to do everything right.
What I really, really liked
and I think is pure genius is ‐‐
What'd you call them?
"Tattoo tours"?
Right.
Yeah.
I see it as a marketing play.
I'm sitting here thinking,
"What can I do for these guys?"
And honestly, I don't know
what I could do.
So for that reason alone,
I'm out.
Thank you, Barbara.
All right.
John:
Here's my thought.
I'm interested
just 'cause I like you,
but I just think
you're doing it already,
and I don't think that
I could add any value to that,
so I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you, Daymond.
Why are you here?
We want to be the premiere
and the face
of tattoo aftercare.
But why are you here?
What are you looking for?
We want an angel
who's gonna be
behind this vision
and believes in our growth.
Okay, guys,
I'll make you the offer.
I like what you're doing.
I'll give you the 500K,
but I want 12%.
♪♪
Wow.
And that's non‐negotiable.
Thank you
for your offer.
for the offer, Mark.
So, you guys ‐‐
Can we discuss?
Sure.
[ Softly ]
We take it.
You could have got more.
♪♪
[ Softly ] We want to hear
what she has.
Lori, do you have ‐‐
Are you crazy?
What are you doing?
Lori, are you
gonna go in?
♪♪
Mark, I know you said
it's non‐negotiable.
Would you consider
working with Lori with us?
No.
Mark Cuban,
you've got a deal.
Thank you so much.
Done. [ Laughs ]
Appreciate it, guys.
Thank you.
All right.
Thank you, guys.
All right, have a good
rest of your day.
Corcoran: Bye.
You're right.
I should have
asked for more.
You should have.
They would have
happily given it.
Yeah, I know.
Agbitor:
I think we made a phenomenal
deal with Mark Cuban.
I am honestly really
speechless right now.
I know my parents
are gonna be really happy,
and I'm gonna be
an inspiration
to my friends
back home in Ghana.
Your mom's gonna be
so proud of you, Selom.
[ Both laugh ]
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is an alternative way
to enjoy bike riding with kids.
[ Both laugh ]
Finally, we're together.
Hi, my name is Aaron Powell,
and I'm from Denton, Texas.
Yo!
My company is Bunch Bikes,
and I'm seeking
$250,000 for 10% equity.
Biking is a wonderful way
for families with young kids
to enjoy the outdoors together,
but the existing
products on the market
could use a fresh perspective.
Imagine you're 3 years old
and about to go on a bike ride
with your parents.
You are so excited
to get outside,
feel the wind on your face,
and enjoy the scenic views.
[ Laughter ]
What if there was a way to bike
that kept
your precious cargo in view?
It's time to say bye‐bye
to the bike trailer
and hello to the Bunch Bike.
The Bunch Bike
is an electric cargo bike
that lets you engage
with your kids while you ride
by putting them up in front.
You can laugh
and talk with them,
point out cool things
along the way,
and make memories together
that will last a lifetime.
And with the Bunch Bike's
spacious front cargo box,
there's enough room
to bring everything you need
for your next family adventure.
Bunch Bikes is sharing
the joy of family biking
across the country.
So who wants to come along
for the ride
and make a bunch of money?
Whoa.
I want to ride.
Oh, actually, I know
you're into biking, Barbara.
I was going to invite you
to come down and...
Seriously?
Oh, great.
Yes. Absolutely.
We're going to have you ride
this red one.
I'm going to put Kevin
in the bike.
I'm so curious to see
how heavy it is.
It's going to be easier
than you think, actually.
Let me help you
with that.
Just put her.
[ Laughter ]
Barbara,
put me back into the Bunch,
or it's over between us.
Whoa.
It's stable, huh?
Yeah.
Is it assisted
electrically?
There is
an electric assist.
The electric assist,
it's easy.
Like, a lot
of our customers
are not necessarily
the most experienced bikers.
and so with
the electric,
I mean,
anybody can do it.
It has parking brakes.
That's a good thing.
Can you take it apart easily
to transport it?
No.
So, the advantage of this bike
is it's got a big box.
You can put a lot of stuff
in it, up to four kids,
picnic, grocery, cooler,
all of that.
But the disadvantage is
it does not come apart
easily for transport.
So your box to ship it's
gonna be pretty big, right?
It is big, and so we actually
only ship these bikes
fully assembled.
We use a motorcycle
shipping company.
That should be
very expensive, though.
It is expensive ‐‐
$450 to ship.
‐Ooh.
‐Wow.
Yes, but it is less expensive
than shipping
the big, cardboard boxes
to the customer
and then having them...
‐Assemble it.
...pay a bike shop
to assemble it.
They're gonna bill
that customer $300.
Aaron, what does
the bike itself cost?
So, we have two
different bikes here.
This is the one that
we've been selling the longest.
We retail it at $4,295.
Oof.
Wow!
‐$4,295?
$4,295. That's right.
So I can buy the bike
or send my kids to college.
[ Laughter ]
$4,295 sounds like a lot.
This one's actually $6,000.
Of course it is.
And we're going for the premium
quality on the market.
So it's basically got
the top‐of‐the‐line
everything component‐wise.
‐Wow.
‐Oh.
Aaron, why did you invent
the bike?
I did not invent this bike.
Oh.
So let me give you a backstory
about how I kind of
came to this idea.
Please do. Okay.
So I actually used to be, like,
a middle‐school band teacher
back in the day, and...
You know, you look like
a middle‐school band teacher.
I guess I'll take that
as a compliment.
That's flattering.
And then everything changed
the day my daughter was born.
And it was like this switch
just, like, flipped in my brain,
like, I don't want
to be a teacher anymore.
And so I call my principal.
I took a 90‐day maternity leave,
and I said,
"Okay, I need to take
this 90 days.
I need to find a business that
I can start that will give me
eventually the freedom to,
you know, put my family first."
And so I actually found
an opportunity
in the online jewelry space.
And over the next 18 months,
I put 5 to 6 hours a night,
all my money back into it.
And then I was double my
teaching salary, and so I quit.
To celebrate,
we took a family trip to Sweden.
And that's actually
where I saw a bike like this
for the first time.
And, you know,
initially, I just thought,
"Hey, that's cool.
I want to get one."
I'm into bikes.
I want to ride with my kids.
We come back to the U. S.
There's not really anywhere
to get one from.
And so I thought,
"Hey, here's an opportunity.
Like, this is, like, something
that a lot of people
would be interested in."
And so I sold the last business
for $300,000.
I paid off all my student loans.
I put $85,000 into the Bunch.
And that's kind of
how we got started.
You sold
an online jewelry business
for $300,000?
That's right.
And it was about two and
a half years after I started it.
Did you buy into this business?
Oh, yeah, yeah, gotcha.
Are you a licensee?
So I just wanted to prove
there was even a market here.
So I started small.
I got one sample from a factory
that was already
making bikes like this
for the European market.
And there was a lot of interest,
a lot of sales
right out the gate
just from my Instagram posts.
That's a $6,000 bike, right?
Yes.
What do you buy it for?
So, landed, I can get this bike
for $2,917.
So as an investor, what am
I really investing in?
I'm investing in a good guy ‐‐
Aaron, the bike guy,
but who's really
a distributor, right?
I don't own
any proprietary technology.
Well, it's...
Really good point.
It's their proprietary design.
They've got it registered.
And, like, the exclusive
distribution is for ‐‐
U.S. and Canada, nobody's gonna
be able to get a bike ‐‐
this bike like this here.
Well, the proof of the pudding
is in your sales.
Lifetime sales ‐‐
$2.7 million.
In what period of time?
Very nice.
We started ‐‐ So our first
full year was 2018.
Wow.
Sold $285,000.
Last year,
we did $1.1 million.
This year,
on track for $2.2 million.
‐Wow.
‐You're killing it.
That's impressive, actually.
Cuban:
You've done a great job.
Don't get me wrong,
right?
You know, $2.2 million
in sales is killing it.
Right? But it's hard for us
to just say, "You know what?
Here's what we're gonna do
to scale your business,
and here's how we can make it
into a ‐‐ you know,
a $50‐million business
or whatever it may be."
Well, can I give you
the long‐term plan?
My goal, my vision, is,
actually, I want to
make these bikes accessible
to more people,
and so to have my own design
at that point,
where we can roll out
5,000 bikes a year
and reach more people, maybe
under a different brand
or something like that.
That's very laudable, right?
It's great.
But that's a lot
of uncertainty.
It's not necessarily
the most capital‐efficient way
for an investor to work,
or at least not for me.
So for those reasons,
I'm out, Aaron.
Thank you, Mark.
You're welcome.
So, Aaron...
Yes?
...I think
it's a cool product.
The problem for me
is, it's not your product.
It's great
that you are able
to sell it here
in the United States.
Sounds like you're doing
a really good job.
But when I invest,
I want to invest in somebody
who's the owner,
the inventor, the entrepreneur,
where they actually ‐‐
It's "their" product
and their company.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Completely understand.
Thank you.
Aaron, the bikes are
a lot of money.
Yes.
There's nothing wrong
with what you're doing.
I just feel a little
uncomfortable asking people
to pay $5,000
for a bike right now
when a lot of people need just
the little necessities in life.
[ Sighs ]
So it's a tough one.
So I'm a customer,
but I'm out.
Okay. I completely
understand that.
Thank you.
I think you've built
a really good business.
I love going into
high‐end verticals.
But you're a distributor.
There's nothing wrong with that.
If I gave you $250,000
and I just took a distribution,
it would be four years
until I got my capital back
and got any kind of return.
So it's a difficult investment
for an investor,
any investor.
So I'm out.
Thank you, Kevin.
Appreciate it.
Barbara?
Well, I'm lukewarm about it.
I love the product.
The business model,
basically,
I'm subleasing
your distribution sort of.
You control
the distribution,
and you're letting us take
a share of it, no?
Okay,
that's how I see it.
I'll give you
a very greedy offer.
You won't be offended,
right?
You can't offend me.
Oh, yes, she can.
♪♪
Narrator: Four Sharks are out,
but Barbara may be interested
in Aaron's high‐end bike
and cart company, Bunch Bikes.
I'll give you
a very greedy offer.
You won't be offended,
right?
You can't offend me.
Oh, yes, she can.
Well, I'll take that back.
Not intentionally.
‐Sweat equity.
‐But I'll give you the $250,000,
but I want 40%.
‐Oh! Barbara!
‐Whoo!
He looks offended to me.
I don't know if "offended"
is the right word.
Are you offended?
He didn't say no yet.
Look, I didn't say no yet.
So you're saying
there's a chance.
Look, for based on what
our net's gonna be this year,
I felt like I came in
with a pretty reasonable offer.
I mean, that's cutting
my valuation so much.
There's nothing reasonable
about Barbara.
I'm bringing
a lot to the table here, too.
Getting this started
was not easy.
In our first year, I had
my first manufacturers screw me.
They had had a typhoon come in,
flood out their factory.
My bikes had been underwater,
like, a foot underwater,
and they shipped them
out to us anyways.
And then I had
to pay tariffs on them.
We get the bikes, open up
that container.
It's like, a flood of humidity
just hits you.
And we knew something
was wrong.
Oh, that's got to be horrible.
We open up the bikes. Water's
pouring out of the motors.
And it's like, it's toast.
Oh, no.
Like, whole container lost.
Get that money back?
Somebody else could have, like,
shipped those bikes out
to customers, but, like, no.
Like, we're gonna do right
by our customers.
I'm gonna take the hit.
That's the first time I had
to take a loan for the business.
You just said you took a loan
for the business.
Does the business
have any debt right now?
Yeah. So right now,
we have $50,000 in loan
that will be paid off
by the end of this year.
I've got $50,000
on credit cards.
And earlier this year,
in April,
I took out a $150,000 SBA loan
that I just put into inventory.
And did you raise any money
from any other investors?
Earlier this year,
I raised $95,000 ‐‐
$45,000
from family and friends
and $50,000
from two angel investors.
Oh, I had no idea
you had borrowed so much money.
It was just because
I was willing to take that risk,
take that on,
but we're profitable.
We're making money.
I'm paying it all down.
I've never missed
a debt payment.
So that being said,
would you take my offer
of $250,000 for 40%?
It's ‐‐
It's more than I could do.
I'm gonna counter
back at you.
I would take $250,000 for 20%.
♪♪
$250,000 for a third.
Would you be open to...
‐No.
‐[ Laughs ]
What if there was maybe
a loan portion of that $250,000?
Say ‐‐ Let's say you did,
you know,
150K as a loan,
$100,000 as equity,
and then the equity
would be, say, 10%?
I'll do it for 15%.
12 1/2%,
you got a deal.
15%, we got a deal.
I love this stuff.
I really do.
Welcome to "Shark Tank."
Barbara, you've got a deal!
‐Yo!
‐Yeah!
‐I like that one!
Mazel tov!
John: There you go.
Corcoran: I want to hug you,
but I can't.
Air hug. There we go.
Hey, hey, hey.
‐Thank you, guys. Appreciate it.
‐Congratulations, man.
♪♪
What this is all about is
setting an example for my kids.
Like, yeah, I'm doing it
for the families out there,
and I'm bringing these bikes
to the world,
but, really, it's about showing
my kids that,
like,
you can do anything you want.
You see a problem in the world,
you can tackle it.
You know, my legacy
is not gonna be Bunch Bikes.
My legacy is gonna be
my children
and the amazing things
that they do.
And that's what really
this is all about.
♪♪